Wien – die Hauptstadt Österreichs.
Berühmt für ihre Architektur
und Geschichte,
ihre Kultur und Musik, den Walzer
und natürlich das Wiener Schnitzel.
Die Metzger der Stadt verraten gerne,
welches Fleisch man für ein echtes
Wiener Schnitzel braucht.
Kalb ist junges Rind, ist fettlos,
praktisch fettlos und ist ganz ganz weich.
Und das Original Wiener Schnitzel entstand
vom, vom Milchkalb.
Also das ist, es ist magerer und
es ist weicher als [wie] Schwein.
Die bekannteste Wiener Adresse
für das berühmte Schnitzel
ist das Restaurant Figlmüller,
ein Familienbetrieb.
Chefkoch Markus Brunner brät
hier jeden Tag dutzende Schnitzel
und weiß, dass es auf die richtige
Vorbereitung des Fleisches ankommt.
Also zuerst wird’s geschnitten
und dann wird's vorsichtig geklopft.
Weil eben Kalbfleisch ist extrem heikel,
hat sehr viel Wasser,
weil es ein junges Kalb ist.
Und gerad beim Klopfen muss man
extrem aufpassen,
dass man wirklich nicht die Faserung
zerstört,
weil wirklich sonst das komplette Wasser
rausgehen würde
und die Schnitzel dann nicht mehr
so schön soufflieren.
Frische Eier, golden aufgeschlagen,
und feine Semmelbrösel
gehören ebenso zu den wichtigen Zutaten
eines Wiener Schnitzels.
Das Kalbfleisch wird leicht gesalzen
und in griffiges Mehl getaucht.
Anschließend in der Eiermasse und danach
in den Semmelbröseln wenden.
Die Brösel werden jetzt nur vorsichtig
angedrückt. Nicht zu stark!
Nun wird das Fleisch in Butterschmalz
gebraten.
Dabei ist es wichtig, das Schnitzel ständig
in Bewegung zu halten,
damit es gleichmäßig braun wird.
Sobald eine goldene Färbung erreicht ist,
das Schnitzel aus der Pfanne nehmen
und das Fett abtropfen lassen.
Eine Light-Variante wäre zum Beispiel,
mit Rapsöl oder Sonnenblumenöl
die Schnitzel rauszubacken.
Wir verwenden Butterschmalz.
Ein guter Tipp ist auch ein bisschen
gemischt mit Sonnenblumenöl.
Das hat den Vorteil, dass, wenn ich
zu Hause das Schnitzel rausbacke,
die ersten Schnitzel werden schön.
Aber dann hast du diese schwarzen Punkte
drinnen vom Butterschmalz,
weil das Butterschmalz dann
leicht verbrennt.
Typische Beilage zum Schnitzel ist
ein Kartoffelsalat.
Bei Figlmüller nimmt man dafür
eigene Kartoffeln,
die von einem nahen Bauernhof kommen
und regelmäßig geliefert werden.
Chefkoch Markus Brunner hilft gerne mit.
Zurück in der Küche laufen die letzten
Vorbereitungen für das Wiener Schnitzel.
Wie viele Portionen jeden Tag
serviert werden,
das bleibt Figlmüllers Geheimnis.
Man verlässt sich auf seinen guten Ruf.
Die Geschichte des Restaurants
beginnt 1905
und lebt mittlerweile in vierter Generation.
In einem Buch erklärt die Familie
ihre Rezepte in anschaulichen Bildern –
das Wiener Schnitzel ist natürlich
auch dabei.
Wer Kalorien zählt,
bevorzugt vielleicht ein Wasser,
aber Weißwein passt am besten.
Und dann heißt es in Wien:
„Guten Appetit!“